du cinéma avec la sortie de demain soir
mardi de spider man
vous connaissez sans doute les aventures
de cet homme mordu par une araignée qui
se découvre des pouvoirs surnaturels
c'est une adaptation bien entendu de la
célèbre bande dessinée le film a déjà
battu quelques records aux états unis
pascal deschamps 40 ans pas un de moins
que les femmes de l'homme araignée
attendait ce moment
une adaptation cinématographique réussie
de la bande dessinée après plusieurs
tentatives qualifié de ridicule
problème de droit bagarre de studio
histoire de gros sous des réalisateurs
pressentis comme james cameron monsieur
titanic qui congédié c'est finalement un
authentique fan de la bd sam raimi qui a
remporté le morceau
quant au rôle titre c'est l'inattendu
toby maguarian spécialiste des films
d'auteur qu'il a décrochés on n'est pas
tous destinés à changer le monde mais
pour moi mener une vie ordinaire
n'est plus vraiment envisageable sam
raimi merlus absolument et c'est plutôt
sympa mais les studios étaient plus
qu'hésitant il a fallu que je fasse une
audition juste au corps pour une scène
d'action et comme j'étais en bonne
condition physique
torse nu j'ai fait les scènes comme ça
voilà un point ce à quoi ça tient
le succès plutôt phénoménal du film lui
tient certainement à la réussite des
scènes d'action grâce au numérique
aujourd'hui le travail d'un réalisateur
est proche de celui du dessinateur de
bande dessinée mais il n'y a pas que ça
qui n'a pas imaginé un jour revêtir un
collant moulant pour sauver le monde
spider man c'est un rêve de gosse
réalisé par procuration celui de
l'invincibilité après un certain 11
septembre à new york serait sans doute
devenu le rêve de toute une nation
attaquer new york c'est nous attaquer
tous dit d'ailleurs la foule au héros
masqué
un dernier détail après le retrait de la
bande annonce nous voyait les twin
towers
elles sont tout de même dans le film une
image subliminale plus qu'un clin d'oeil
un symbole